here's another question from one of your
fans how old are you 30 okay
yes yeah I saw someone asked if you
hooked up with Tana
uh that's a yes okay moving on that's a
yes if you haven't tripped in a hallway
and possibly hugged no you hooked up if
you can't answer right away nothing
crazy Tana Tana's been on here she's
great and she talked about hooking up
with you she didn't stop bring her in
okay or Amanda okay the crutches are
coming in get a shot this is your son
yeah what he heard himself dancing what
are you doing is this a part of this
what yes
for who
you just now what did I get a gift wait
Trevor's on the show yeah yeah is this a
bit he's a president he's Tana's friend
right yeah you know tan Tana is great
here I got it oh that what is that I was
about to find out YouTube black what is
it
oh we got it did we get a flag
yeah
I think you're black you got a million
plaque I do I know what is that one this
is probably just 100
000. oh yeah throw that away what are we
doing well you crutched in for that come
on now I'm kidding I'm kidding that's
awesome now look who's now you're 100
uh this is what says do you remember the
first subscriber no I don't
uh you're 100. I subscribed first this
is for like goldfish oh my God
oh my oh that's awesome that's that's
great dude put it up here that's awesome
congrats man wow you you remember when
you got yours oh yeah I was ecstatic I
hung it up right above my bed and this
was back when I had like the bed the bed
at Ralphs the better Ralph the purple
mattress at Rouse a thunderstorm that
was rain that was my headboard I didn't
have one so I was like perfect and then
next one is a million next one's a
million and then you've got a million I
don't have that one you have the one
million subscribers I do that's
fantastic it's awesome you have three
though you have three million so they
don't give you a new one for every
million you don't have three one million
subscriber plants I wish God that'd be
cool
how long did it take you from the 100
000. to the million it is a good
question uh
maybe about like a year I'm not really
sure well I can't wait till next year
thank you everybody thank you sauce how
do we how do we get from this to a
million thank you everybody well I mean
here's the good guests yeah good guests
like Trevor Wallace 100K on a podcast is
like like that's very hard to do like a
podcast alone to get people to subscribe
to it is you know that's people who love
and listen to your show every week so
that's like 100k those are like a
dedicated 100. so can I tell you
something not only are they dedicated
they're awesome so we do listen to your
uh suggestions do you know how many tons
and tons of people said why don't you
when are you gonna get Trevor Wallace on
I guess because it's YouTube and yeah
they love they love you yeah you've had
some great guests I see I see yourself
pop up all the time
[Music]